bitcoin is creating all kinds of fear in
the market but again stop being fearful
what am i talking about bitcoin has not
been this oversold since the pandemic
began the bitcoin rsi ends up measuring
the relative strength index it looks at
how oversold or overbought an asset is
that momentum indicator goes ahead and
shows us exactly what is happening in
the market when we look at the rsi right
now you can see that there is immense
overselling of bitcoin it means there's
maximum fear maximum pain in the market
literally there are more people who are
want to sell bitcoin right now than in
most times in history now the last time
that bitcoin's rsi was this low was back
in march of 2020. bitcoin dropped 50 in
a single day it was completely oversold
and then it rallied back aggressively
before that it went down in november in
december of 2018 the bottom of the 2018
bear market completely oversold that
final puke from 6 500 down to around 3
000
ultimately what history has shown us is
that historically whenever rsi gets this
significantly oversold it shows that
it's usually a pretty good indicator
that there is likely to be a rapid price
increase following now again the pass is
not an indicator of what's going to
happen in the future but this one metric
is really important and it puts it in
perspective when you see just how
oversold how fearful how worried people
are in the market but let's go ahead and
look at the fear and greed index itself
what is that showing us well ladies and
gentlemen the bitcoin fear and greed
index is showing us extreme fear
everyone is scared everyone is panicking
extreme fear of 13 on that fear and
greed index
now extreme fear yesterday extreme fear
last week extreme fear that is what the
market is telling us that is what this
index is telling us so ultimately what
you have to do is you got to block out
the noise you got to remember the old
quote buy when there is blood in the
streets be greedy when everyone else is
fearful
be fearful when everyone else is greedy
now i don't know what's going to happen
in the future in terms of bitcoin's
price but what i do know is that
everyone else in the market is very
fearful there's literally blood all
throughout all these charts everything
is bleeding assets are selling off and
so ultimately it doesn't feel good you
get that knot in your stomach and if you
follow those timeless investing
principles from the charlie mongers of
the world the warren buffets and many
other of those that have been put on the
pedestal of investing
this is usually when they actually make
their courageous bets now again there's
immense risk maybe bitcoin keeps going
down maybe other cryptocurrencies keep
going down nobody knows what's going to
happen in the future you got to do your
own research you got to make sure that
you actually understand the market you
understand the asset you're buying and
you only invest the money that you're
willing to risk but it's important to
remember just how fearful people are
there's quantifiable metrics it's
extreme fear 13 on that index rsi sold
off immensely
ladies and gentlemen
we haven't been here many times
but the last few times we were here
generational opportunity
and so maybe history repeats maybe it
doesn't i don't know
again i don't know
but what i do know is that this isn't
the first time we've been here and
people should have that historical
perspective in order to understand
exactly what's happening right now john
what do you think about all this yeah
people are just fearful in the market
rsi is a good indicator of that because
it's a momentum indicator um ranging
from zero to 100 right but
the same thing we're seeing the same
thing with stocks we're seeing the same
things with other assets as well that
people are very fearful and there's
momentum moving down right now um and
you would expect that to kind of rebound
in the coming months or years right uh
but yeah it's people are extremely
fearful 13 extreme
extreme greed that's what happens when
you have a massive price draw down so
quickly
joe what do you think i mean imagine if
you would have seen that uh extreme fear
knowing it was at 35 000 30 000 whatever
in uh a year or two ago right the the
reaction would be much different uh and
there would be heavy heavy greed going
on so i think you know it's just a sign
of kind of where we are uh reaching 69
000 earlier this year uh and people are
fearful when they see the price drop
like this they're they get fearful uh
and they don't know what's exactly going
to happen especially with an uncertain
kind of future from the fed